stunt driver Chris Joe is about to drive
over a bridge in the Chinese city of
Suzhou it's not an ordinary bridge
designed by artist Steve mesm it's a
bridge made of sheets of paper and
absolutely nothing else this can't be
possible
you would find me driving across
anything like that this is awesome
yes it is amazing we caught up with
Steve in his studio in England to see
how he built his paper bridge and then
we have the formwork in the middle this
is exactly the same paper that we used
in China it's just red and then we just
stack the paper from both sides at the
same time when we come up to the middle
then we take the chocks away from down
the bottom and we can just slide it out
and then the arch will just stay on but
how can flimsy sheets of paper support
the weight of a car if you're going to
build a bridge out of paper and you're
not going to use any other materials
like cables or glue and arch is
definitely the way to go it arced like
this all the pieces are angled so that
gravity pulls them into each other so
the pieces on the side are wanting to
fall in towards the center but the
pieces in the center are pushing back so
everything just gets locked into place
but the ends of the bridge there are two
abutments and they stop the bridge from
actually splaying out with and a result
is a very strong structure